Boeing CEO could face new calls to step
down when he testifies before Housley
lawmakers today after a bruising Senate
hearing about that 737 max jet
despite his apologetic tone yesterday
Denis Muhlenberg said he is not
resigning for the first time though he
acknowledged that he did know that a
pilot expressed concerns about the 737
max before a second deadly crash Kris
Van Cleave is on Capitol Hill with more
on this story Chris it had to be so hard
for the families to hear the CEO say
those words and I know there's more to
come today what can we expect
oh good morning it was a hard day for
the families yesterday we expect there
will be a lot more questions about that
admission from Dennis Muhlenberg about
what he knew and when he knew it now
this has the potential to be an even
more contentious hearing the House
Transportation Committee has been
intensely investigating Boeing for
months all 67 members of this committee
can ask questions so it's going to be a
long day in the hot seat for mr.
mellenburg right here this as there are
now growing calls for changes at the top
of Boeing you're the CEO the buck stops
with you one by one
senators went after Boeing CEO Dennis
Muhlenberg I would walk before I was to
get on a 737 max I would walk Muhlenberg
admits mistakes were made in designing a
plane and apologized to the families of
the 737 max victims some in the audience
but he said he's not quitting these two
accidents occurred on my watch and I
have a keen sense of responsibility to
see that through he seemed to
acknowledge the max should have been
grounded after the first crash one year
ago I think about that decision over and
over every day and if we knew everything
back then that we know now we would have
made a difference by law the FAA
delegates much of the authority for an
aircraft's approval to Boeing senators
were frustrated Muhlenberg had no
suggestions for specific reforms to that
approval process if I were listening to
his testimony today as a member of that
board I would ask for his resignation
and some members increasingly sound like
they want to change the laws to give
more oversight to the FAA not the
manufacturer you have to properly
diagnosis you have to accept
responsibility for what happened so you
we actually can make those those changes
both in with in Boeing also within the
FAA for the first time Muhlenberg met
with victims families after the hearing
you have said you wanted to see Dennis
Muhlenberg and his executive staff and
handcuffs do you still think he should
face charges I still think he should
face charges if they would have acted
after lion air from what they knew we
would not have had my daughter would be
alive we expect a number of families to
attend this hearing as well Boeing says
it is in the final stages of the work to
fix the problems with the 737 max which
sets the stage for the FAA to
potentially test and approve the plane
for flight before the end of the year
Gail all right Kris Van Cleave reporting
thank you very much